ben ali désilets corps et devait
rejoindre ses amis le soir du 19
décembre 2015 mais elle s'est tué dans
un accident
c'était un choc liste juste surmonté
tout acier en ce moment rompuy assure
garder de la peau gros ce qui se passe
et le fait que c'est sûr on se dit que
pour être avec nous piller et l'autre la
jeune femme de 18 ans roulait sur la 138
à saint-cuthbert dans lanaudière
quand elle est allée percuter une
voiture en sens inverse la collision a
aussi fait deux morts dans l'autre
voiture
dans son rapport le coroner explique que
la jeune conductrice avait les facultés
affaiblies par l'alcool est aussi les
drogues et en éclats au père du départ
un nombre des frères c'est pas juste
nous que perdu une amie la dalle
enfin au début j'étais fort chez les
géants voulez mais je pouvais pas me
permet d'y en vouloir parce qu'il était
mort selon la saaq de 2011 à 2015 ya 30
% des conducteurs âgés entre 16 et 24
ans qui sont morts dans un accident de
voiture qui avait consommé la drogue
avec la légalisation du cannabis au
canada on songe entre autres à augmenter
les mesures de sensibilisation à l'école
de conduite technique par exemple on est
en pleine refonte de la matière
théorique sur la drogue au volant
une partie de l'information et tous ses
envoyés par courriel aux parents pour
lui également les informer pour qu'ils
jouent leur rôle d'acteur à
conscientiser aussi
nouvelle théorie donc y aussi une autre
approche dans les cours pratiques le
rôle du moniteur c'est de faire délier
avec l'élève justement sur la matière
qui a pris à l'intérieur des cours des
théories sont d'accord les écoles qui
vous avait parlé par exemple
l'association des écoles de conduite du
québec travaillent d'ailleurs sur une
formation destinée aux moniteurs
elle va aussi organiser une conférence
en mars et ce en plus de sujets déjà
abordés sur ces réseaux sociaux et en
classe la saaq impose un minimum de
matière que les écoles peuvent bonifier
ils vont parler d'eux les effets vont
parler de du danger vont parler des
coûts que ça représente six fonds prend
ou à l'école de conduite vachon en
bourse
on va déjà plus loin lorsque le moniteur
a des doutes sur les capacités de
l'élève
il lui fait passer un test antidopage ça
fait prendre conscience aux gens que oui
il ya des tests existants présentement
c'est un solo sont peu reconnue au
niveau légal
ça veut pas dire que la police par
contre ne peut pas retirer le permis de
conduire
on imagine debout devant moi quand ils
le peuvent et qui se dit toujours ça
arrive aux autres salles arrive juste
aux autres mais quand ça t'arrive à toi
tu vois les choses différemment
la dissuasion passe aussi par ce message
atteint à terre une prompte aux nôtres
je t'oublie jamais trop dedans pour
partir puis dites à vos proches que vous
les aimez ici marie laurence de l'aîné
radio canada saint-hubert